can any of you guess what book that is
I'm using in the thumbnail of this video
probs if you can totally at the end of
the video what it is Death Note gonna
address this right off the top I know
this is based on an anime I've never
seen the anime I didn't know about the
anime someone judging this movie I'm
going to judge it based on the movie
just so you know
alright let's judge so Death Note is a
direct to Netflix movie that's based on
anime like I said the premise is this
dude in high school comes across this
book where if you write someone's name
in the book and how you want them to die
this demon voice by willem dafoe will
make it happen
so this kid actually does the cool thing
I said the cool thing most people who
get a book like this that make it really
selfish and all about them is kids like
now we can make the world right we can
wipe out criminals and that's what they
do they don't try to hide it it's
actually a really interesting thing I
would do exactly that if I had this
Death Note book if you're like alright
Damon we can play ball let's clean up
the world shall we I get a big moral
lecture from everybody but I'd do it so
there's this big investigation this one
dude named el who's really good at
deductions he's like I'm gonna figure
this [ __ ] out
and many tonal shifts throughout the
movie we have ourselves a movie about
death and notes now a lot of people on
Twitter were like oh we need you to
review this movie you need to murder it
it's [ __ ] it's an abomination like I
said I've never seen the animation so
basing it on the movie and entertained
I'd say the movies not without its flaws
first of all the main dude DC well yeah
they could have bigger the cast is
better yes in his delivery I was like
this is you got Willem Dafoe and you got
this kid this movie starts out like it's
gonna be a final destination gorefest
that can entertain me so we'll say the
middle section of the movie concentrates
on the investigation I wish the movie
was longer because that middle part the
investigation is where you can tell they
wanted to make this movie more legit
that it actually came across as this
movie could have been the next dark cult
hit or something that's what they wanted
this movie to be you can tell halfway
through it's about the time they start
putting down the logistics of the rules
at one point she's like oh the internet
says if this guy's an [ __ ] he should
die and dudes like well how do we know I
really like that it's just intelligence
among the characters and the movie
that's just an internet rumor we can't
kill people on internet rumors and tell
me if more people out there had logical
people like this dude in there ring
there would have been a lot less videos
this past weekend content in general
about how Batman's not going to be in
the DC EU and then in the last act of
the movie they straight up throw the
towel and it becomes away a young adult
dad had to happen I guess because you
have a boy and a girl in high school
she's one of my flaws in the movie the
dude shouldn't have been in high school
what's the point of him being in high
school and if he's in high school in the
anime it doesn't matter don't go out on
a leap here I imagine [ __ ] in this movie
is different from the anime so if you're
out there changing stuff why not just
have him not be in high school have him
a twenty something year old maybe he's
down on his luck the point of the movie
has nothing to do with high school going
to the movie is this dude's moral
compass is telling him that he should
write people's names and kill them
because it's for the betterment of
mankind and the investigator named el he
made a couple leaps and he got there
really fast he's like I've deduced
whoever's doing this needs to see the
person's face and needs to know their
name but how'd you get that granted
you're not wrong but everyone who's died
also is not a paraplegic maybe you need
use of both your legs but there's more
to it than that I just feel like the
dude got lucky and happened to be right
and I feel like that because we weren't
along for his process of elimination and
they cut that out because I wanted to
concentrate on the young adult [ __ ] and
I liked el in this movie I really did I
just felt like there's more of a story
there with it and again I felt like they
were in the situation where they're like
we need to keep this movie short ish
fact is he's probably a little nuts
probably a little broken you see a bit
of unorthodox nature to the do but when
you find out a little bit about his past
you're like now why'd you just breeze
over that in the end Death Note has an
interesting premise which is what I say
about every movie based on an anime the
lead actor fell flat for me his romantic
interest that whole love dynamic didn't
work however what they do with the Death
Note was cool I could have used a little
more of the relationship between him and
the death demon to show a little dude
there's a demon whispering in this dudes
ear an actual demon if they had
concentrated more on the investigative
aspect that would have liked that and
the tonal shifts really throw me off
especially when you're gonna end with a
young adult shed it's better than ghost
in the shell' however I still got to say
Death Note probably be a better time if
I were a little drunk yeah no it's a
birdie just a little drunk little drunk
fact is I'd probably say it's a good
time no alcohol required at Matt and a
price but there's no matinee price it's
on Netflix to just watch it and as
promised the book in the thumbnail of
this video is actually my absolute
sandman vol 2 that's as good a book
isn't it yet better than most alright
guys so death note have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you
[Music]